welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar applications of
micro physiological systems for
respiratory drug discovery opportunities
and challenges presented by dr. David
Rowland's senior investigator and group
leader respiratory biology Novartis
Institutes for biomedical research
my name is Xavier Gutierrez and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots leverage is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and type your questions into the drop
down box our speaker will respond to
your questions via email following the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the ask a question box to let us know
that you're experiencing a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
followed the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Roland I will
now turn the presentation over to him
great well thank you very much for the
introduction and giving me the
opportunity to present to you today and
discuss the application of such MDS
systems at - respira - drug discovery
and we like to highlight some of the
opportunities and this kind of
technology offers - drug discovery and
but also discuss some of those
challenges
so first of all of course that the lung
is a highly complex organ it's and
uniquely evolved to support its primary
functions first of all in terms of gas
exchange and you can see from this image
it is a fluorescent micrograph of an
alveolus and you can see the red
fluorescence is actually the endothelial
surface and it's actually a very thin
barrier and this is ofcourse highly
evolved to provide a minimum distance
for oxygen and co2 to diffuse across and
to enable gas exchange and of course it
is really a critical role in ensuring
and maintaining tissue oxygenation
throughout the body surface blood coming
in and surrounding the alveolus will and
it will release co2 that diffuses across
into the alveolar and then removed as we
exhale and bringing oxygen actually back
into the alveolus when we breathe in and
in this of course in reoxygenate blood
going out into the systemic circulation
in addition to its role in regulating
gas exchange and the longer with you
being directly exposed to the atmosphere
has a key role in sensing the external
environment and responding to pathogens
is a very critical role in host defense
so of course when we look further down
into the lung at a cellular level we see
again this complexity further actually
in terms of it the evolution of the cell
types lineages room throughout the lung
is how to uniquely evolved to support
the titular functions of the lung and
throughout the airway tree first of all
looking at the portion of the lung and
the lung the epithelial surface that is
directly facing the gas exchange area
just with oxygen area is really
populated with cells that either express
a ciliated brush head structures that
you can see in this electron micrograph
as have a critical role in beating and
moving particles out of the airway the
other major cell type in this upper area
are actually goblet cells that produce
mucus mucus has a critical role in
trapping particulate matter and in the
cilia can beat and actually move this
mucus up the airway tree where we might
follow it and
move it from potentially damaging a bit
further the epithelial cells further
down the airway tree so really there's
the lung throughout the OHP but it
really has a very compiler evolved and
structure and function again if you look
down at the gas exchange area that I
mentioned the previous slide can see
here that the alveolus is made up of two
principal cell types alveolar epithelial
type one cells and alveolar type two
cells tattoo cells are really
responsible for producing surfactant
which lines the alveolus reduce the
surface tension and keeps the alveoli
open so again another critical role in
maintaining gas exchange
okay so what we're looking at on this
slide is actually the structural
remodeling that occurs within a lung in
a certain disease State
so you can see in the left hand side
you're looking at histology sections of
patients with COPD cystic fibrosis and
asthma and down at the bottom
interstitial fibrosis so first of all on
the left hand side what we see is really
a greatly as thick and increased
thickening of the two muscle cell layer
around these large airway so it provides
this restrictive effect on the lung
tissue in addition to which there's an
inflammation and disorganization of the
epithelium if we look at the asthma
section you can see this blue staining
there and that's actually a mucous plug
that forms in the airway of these
patients
there's expansion of this goblet prayer
cells within their conducting airway
that produced large amounts of mucus and
can completely occlude the flow of air
through the lung and so and then moving
further down to the bottom there's the
calmly fibrosis section that you see
there this is a disease that really
affects the alveolar gas exchange region
and actually has a fact of thickening
the the distance that oxygen has to
diffuse through across this interstitial
barrier so if you remember on the
previous slide that I showed you this
very thin membrane through which and
oxygen diffuses is greatly enlarged in
that disease state so across the net
downstream effect is to reduce gas
exchange and tissue or tissue
oxygenation
so I hope you can appreciate from these
histological sections there's actually
the complexity of these structural
changes that occur in the lung
got through muscle cell expansion
epithelial lineage changes
there's also mucus accumulation
inflammatory cell influx a very
complicated multicellular
processes and it becomes a real
challenge for us in thinking about them
designing and testing new therapies that
target these mechanisms that would
really provide benefit to patients in
the long run the go beyond the existing
standard of care which primarily target
their way constriction or em if the
inflammatory effects associated with
these diseases
so like the spirit restorative discovery
is very similar to the discovery and
other and diseases and somatic areas
there's a high degree of attrition what
typically we typically start out with
they're screening and running a house
throughput screen reads of a million
compounds are often profiled and we then
take the promising leads out of the HTS
strategy progression through a
preclinical pipeline which is really the
role that III support within the
respiratory department at fed liver and
really thinking about ways that we can
triage compounds coming up with assays
in vitro and in vivo to make informed
decisions about which compounds to
ultimately progress really out of these
data can refer to the smaller subsets of
compounds oh one or two would ultimately
progress from toxicology studies into
the clinical domain and then eventually
it's successful on to FDA review but you
see overall is a high degree of
attrition as we move forward and and and
of course this is a very long process
and so one thing I'm very interested in
is thinking about ways that we can make
more informed decisions around compounds
to progress improving the translate
ability of assays and models that we use
to choose between compounds and
hopefully expedite and drug discovery
efforts and through through these
initiatives
so just to discuss as pointed out in a
bit more detail you'll see on this slide
is a typical and drug discovery
flowchart that we'd normally use and
again starting with a target of interest
with establish a HTS assay formats cream
large numbers of compound from an in
vitro standpoint off the move this is
learning to lead optimization to
progress really advanced advanced hits
out of the HTS it within the lead
optimization bucket typically have a
biochemical assays and cell line
experiment and in standards for primary
cell acid and would be typically around
96 well F cells growing up plastic
potentially with one or two very simple
readout and often we end up with a fair
number of compound to then test in vivo
and either who's been pharmacokinetics
pharmacogenomic assays and to really
determine target engagement understand
how PK property to sec that and then
from there progressed into toxicology
ultimately and then if the compound is
disease being suitably safe ultimately
only
to say it's wrong first in man's studies
I would like to do is just discuss a
kind of typical approach that we've been
taking around a lead optimization vivo
pharmacology and this preclinical space
that I mentioned I've been primarily
focused on and really where we do these
micro fluidic systems and micro
physiological assets could be applicable
to kind of expedite MSS in that space so
first of all we would typically you can
see our milk on this assayed it is this
slide actually we want one primary cell
assay we typically use like in other is
another disease areas we grow airway
epithelial cells and in culture these
are typically fairly low throughput
assays just to explain here what we're
looking at we typically grow as human
bronchial epithelial cells on these
trans well inserts that you can see on
the on this schematic on the right hand
side they grow to confluency under
submerged conditions but we actually
remove the apical and media compartment
around seven days into culture if you
leave these cells for further a couple
of weeks and out they start to
differentiate to produce ciliated in
goblet cells
do you remember I explained earlier
really make up to the major cell types
as if you your cell types and in the
conducting airway and this confocal
image 90 demonstrates that the red
fluorescence is showing good and where
the cilia are actually present and the
green and yellow goblet cells that m4
and produce mucus on the right hand side
you'll see a video shortly which really
shows that even under these static
conditions you can see cilia beating we
just play that movie now
okay and so and what you'll see there is
the cilia beating and in unison and but
really one of the key challenge that we
face with this at a culture system is
really the relatively low throughput but
you're only of course dealing with one
of the cell types involved in formation
if these remodel there is the lung
indices so it's really very a very
simplified way of looking at it disease
mechanism in the lung and then typically
we will from then we would move on into
in vivo pharmacology studies or
pharmacokinetics pharmacodynamics type
studies and again with lung air confer
endpoints there are a number of standard
approaches to assessing efficacy of
compounds we typically use and invasive
lung function procedures is a fabricator
fairly widely used in there in the
community and we may combine that with
histological endpoint to assess
structural remodelling but obviously we
kind of the key issues really hard here
are that these are reviewing with
rodents are not the same as human there
they really lack the complexity in many
cases and that we see in histological
specimens from human lungs in terms of
in vivo moles in general for a
spiritually often entail single
administrations of inflammatory agents
and they often progress very fast and
often can be reversible as well so it's
really again I they're very kind of
distinct and pathology to that which we
see in humans so often we use these
assays models for optimizing compound
property is selecting maybe a lead
molecule to progress further and but
really also question marks around the
translate ability of these to the
patient setting and you wonder if this
is a as the potential source of
disconnect when we start testing
compounds in a clinic down the line so
one way that we've we've been over the
last couple of years we've been looking
out to try and to try and get around
some of these challenges is to think
about using ex vivo preparation so this
is an initiative we've been working on
the last couple of years and potentially
using ex vivo assays and models as a
bridge and to the clinic and the reason
being that we think they offer some
advantages you can see here is an
example an isolated perfuse lung system
that we
if we've used it in the in the
department and its name suggests with
what we're looking at here our rodent
lungs that have been removed from the
animal and they're ventilated and
perfused so really preserving much of
the physiology that you would get in
vivo but the advantages that they offer
a lot of flexibility and in terms of
access to a different compartment such
as the inhale through we can deliver
molecules directly to the lung and
mimicking inhale delivery
we can also add compound directly to the
systemic compartment to mimic or nor all
dose for instance and we can directly
study the uptake and penetration of
molecules into different compartments in
the lung using this method and so if we
then move to the next slide what we see
here is taking this model system of
steps further forward beyond NPK and by
distribution studies we can also use the
system to study and probe and mechanism
of action in this example what I'm
showing here is we're taking the
isolated perfused lung and been able to
combine it with fluorescence microscopy
and to directly image the lung tissue in
real time in this experiment we've
perfused the lung with calcium dyes that
the yellow and green fluorescence that
you can see in the image on the right
and we can record and these calcium
responses in real time to assess the
regional differences in calcium
transients between the vascular and
airway compartment that have labeled
they're on the image just reported
through without without looks like you
can see here that in this experiment
we've actually perfused the lung which
human occurs to factor alpha it's a very
potent pro-inflammatory stimuli and this
R then enables us to studies direct
calcium responses in the lung tissue and
particularly of interest to assess the
effect of TNF alpha in different
compartments of the lung airway versus
vasculature and you can see here that
there clearly this is from calcium
increase and so we can use the types of
approaches to then study the effect of
pharmacological agents of blocking TNF
alpha signaling and its effectiveness
that they're doing this in different
regions of the lung
we also used the isolated profuse lung
to probe and other physiological
properties of the lung such as directly
measuring lung function and as an
example plot on the right hand side
showing a simple dose response to
acetylcholine which produces a very
marked the airway constrictor response
and we can also measure edema in real
time in this out is missing in this ex
vivo SI system and then the final
graphic can also measure pulmonary humor
dynamics - so you can get a very
integrated physiological assessment
that's not easy to do in an in vivo
setting to give you really depth of
understanding about how a compound might
be working and of course the number of
ex vivo systems available to respiratory
drug discovery and absolutely perfuse
lung being one of them
but typically a lot of limitations are
at it and they often have very limited
lifespan the IPL is really only viable
for in around six hours that you can
extend it up to 24 hours if you alter
some of the parameters and the Tokyo
tissues similarly there are useful for
very very short-term experiments and I'm
if eclis also very low throughput so
while they address some of the
challenges that I highlighted earlier
just a lot could have getting close to
really being able to kind of get a
comprehensive physiological system and
also being able to use human tissue as
well so that's really where I've become
very interested in using micro
physiological systems to try and get us
closer to a translational model of lung
physiology and just to take a step back
from that the reason being there
coursing typically growth and primary
cells and static also conditions you're
lacking a lot of the basic physiology
that occurs in the lung there's no
mechanical stretch there's no perfusion
there's no exposure to and direct
exposure to the atmosphere like you
would get in the lung and so some of the
approach is to get around this of course
we can think about using and organoids
systems and and I think these are really
can observe you know great assay systems
for replicating a particular cellular
needs
and there's an example here from no
publication a couple of years ago were
able to grow human airway epithelial
cells bronchial epithelial cells in this
case and maintain their and danisha they
were typically occupy in the normal lung
producing ciliated and goblet cells into
and releasing mucus which is a green
fluorescence that you can see something
the great has a mimicking in the
physiological micro environment at the
airway and also this potential
scalability with the organized to at
least against the 384-well as a format
to be able to run larger screens but
they're sort of still deficient in
certain physiological mechanisms and
thinking about translate ability to the
whole lung another that includes and for
example parameters such as and the
stretch forces that the lungs normally
exposed to as we breathe until you see
here is an example from the end of each
Institute them here in Cambridge that
published there's the lung on the chip
model back in 2010 and is really elegant
assay system so the small chip based
system that includes a porous membrane
very thin membranes are ten microns in
thickness
and it was what you can do here is to
grow airway epithelial cells in in close
proximity with endothelial cells and you
can really mimic for example the
alveolus of the lung and using this to
this approach in familiar with some of
the major advantages here is that
they're the chip is connected to a pump
so you can actually perfuse the chip
through the vascular compartment and the
end of your cells below are directly
exposed to the normal flow and
mechanisms normal flow forces that
actually have the clear biological
effects and any fear yourselves that can
affect polarization intracellular
signaling effects so it's a very
important physiological property it's
similar with the airway channel you can
also force through air to mimic the
effect of forced air breathing on it's
really kind of the effective airflow on
on the lung epithelium and again this
also has effect to in terms of signaling
and phenotypical alterations on the
lumbers closer to to what we see in the
intact lung and I think though the
really kind of key bit here is the
stretch ability to really mimic
those dynamic forces that these cells
are normally exposed to so we can really
imagine it's a very clear advantage over
and above these static monocultures that
we know typically have been used to
empty support of discovery in
respiratory so for the next couple of
slides releated highlight a couple of
really nice examples of where and such
systems have been used and it would be
applicable to drug discovery and so the
first approach here micro physiological
system really being a system capable of
emulating human physiology and I think
that's that's really very kind of really
reflective is lemonade chip technology
combining these physiological forces
with a human primary cells and you can
also cross substitute wild-type cells
for COPD or IPS cells for instant access
to the patient derived cells and so in
this example here it's actually an
application around toxicology he was a
very nice one and in this case is
looking at the non target issue
associated with il-2 which is used to
treat certain forms of cancer so il-2
does in the lung is to increase a
barrier permeability and it did make
patients predisposed to developing edema
in the airway so where they as the lungs
fill with fluid and impaired last
exchange ultimately so that serves as an
important problem associated with the
type of approach where you can see him
in panel B then the team used this
lung-on-a-chip technology with the
airway epithelium groaning croats
association with the endothelium and on
the on the right hand side you see there
that there's a bright field view of the
the fit of the epithelial surface
looking down into the chips a really
nice confluence cells grown in this
system the assay design here's our the
team perfused the system with il-2
through the vascular compartment but the
food is bright field imaging they're
actually able to image the onset of
edema in the chip did you see all those
on the margins of the figure on day one
that's labeled a1 you see very clear
margins and that really define the
boundary of where there's a meniscus due
to the fluid and actually the
surfaces we can clearly see on the top
over time with il-2 treatment and those
the margins of meniscus the fluid layer
starts to expand and start to take over
the entire surface of the chip by day
four you don't even see the cells
anymore because it's completely covered
by a fluid and then the bottom path the
bottom panel where the team as you
demonstrated the other mechanism
associated with il-2 treatment is
actually increased in fibrin matrix
deposition in the alveolar regions and
so what they did here is to perfuse the
chips with prothrombin and for bringing
alongside il-2 and were able to very
nicely and clearly show formation of
this fibrin clot on the alveolar
epithelial surface of the chips
something this is to be really
highlights a very nice application of
this system where you can actually
replicate a toxicology finding that's
observed in rodents in this chip system
where you're using human cells and and
and of course it reduces the need to to
test those types of approaches in it in
animals you can replicate it here I
think it really could be broader
applications to in thinking about and
drug therapies to target pulmonary edema
as well this type of approach may be
applicable there as well
after moving on to a second example and
what we're what we're looking at here is
it really as an example of where the
team have used the lung on the chip
technology to study efficacy of
potential new therapies to treat asthma
and so in this experiment what they're
doing and taking of the lung on the chip
technology growing and primary and
epithelial cells on the air surface
endothelial cells again on the blood
channel that we can see there as labeled
that's diffused with blood and also of
course air is blown across the surface
of the epithelial layer the panel's DNE
nicely show that the the intact mono
layers of both the epithelium and the
endothelium and he was really nice about
this approach if you look a panel at you
clearly see the movie example that
showed you earlier the ciliated
epithelium here we nicely see a large
amount of ciliated cells which is the
green fluorescence that we can see these
Tufts of cilia and there's an electron
micrograph in panel G which shows very
high degree of silly Asian and which is
quite reflective of what we see if you
take a human lung tissue and stain it up
for these types of markers you see very
dense layers of stent areas of ciliated
epithelium and panel H M shows that in
fact these cilia are functionally active
as well as a time-lapse image series
showing me these Tilley are all beating
in unison and in a very coordinated way
I mean she's actually quite distinct
from what we've seen typically in in
human airway epithelial cells grown in
these standard Transvaal inserts that I
showed you on a few slides ago but you
don't typically see such a high degree
of ciliated epithelial formation and
also the cilia can often be in a in a
fairly and discordant way and we believe
this is really due to the fact that this
chip-based system the lungs exposed to
normal mechanical forces so they would
be in vivo so health cilia align with
the direction of flow or air flow in
this case and so it gives us a much more
physiologically relevant and system here
but just getting to the key experiment
here what the team did was to expose
and the chip to aisle 13 interleukin 13
is a major pro-inflammatory cytokine
that is highly regulated in asthmatic
patients what it does on the airway
epithelium is to promote the
differentiation or Fareway attitude
yourselves into goblet cells it really
drives a goblet cell formation at the
expense of ciliated cells because where
you can see from that the downstream
effect of that phenotype is really there
and you're going to get much more mucus
produced in the airway and you just not
going to have enough cilia to remove
that mucus so you start to get all that
mucus buildup in the a way which is
really a classic hallmark event of a
somatic patient which is a nicely
replicating here and it's also
quantified in the image below and
there's in a figure below in terms of
the compounds that were tested here's a
nice example that the chip is also
exposed to a steroid dexamethasone which
is a really standard of care in asthma
although there's a large number of
patients that unfortunate don't respond
to dexamethasone as a treatment and you
can see here that then the Dex group is
actually not reducing the number of
goblet cells but interestingly the tall
test cater to the test compounds that
were added here so it's a jak 1
inhibitor
if the novel target has been identified
and there is playing a role in the
goblet cell formation you can see is
really giving quite a robust and
reduction in a number of goblet cells
and what I really liked about this in a
publication overall is that you did
really kind of demonstrating the power
of this system that you can combine
these types of readout attempts as
they're looking at number of goblet
cells with real-time functional data so
looking at the physiology in real time
so that Cecilia beating in this case and
we can see very nicely that then the the
jak1 inhibitor is those dependently
increasing cilia beat frequency and as
it's reversing the number of goblet
cells in the chip system so altogether
you get a much more comprehensive
picture of what's going on here is you
start at rit explore new therapies that
these diseases not only looking at
number of goblet cells but also looking
at the downstream physiology so it was
pretty promising as a potential
a to to triage compounds down the line
perhaps relooking in a more competent
ideological systems such as the micro
physiological system and did to select
compounds for in vivo testing perhaps so
that brings me back to and to this this
flow chart that I showed at the
beginning of typical flow chart of how
drug discovery projects may be
progressed in in respiratory and coming
back to some of the new approaches that
could be adopted here do you think there
is it for example looking at using
organoids that i mentioned that they can
replicate and some of the airway niches
that occur in a normal life keeping
cells in their physiological micro
environment and but also having a
scalability aspect to that could be
applicable for and maybe even HTS
activities if we can scale them to such
a level and then of course there's very
applicable for lead optimization
activities using primary cells grown in
this format i think the power of the
micro physiological systems i think they
do really plug into these later stage
activities in the flowchart
that they could be that could be really
used to assess their multiple
physiological parameters and as lead
compounds that are coming out of HTS and
ultimately kind of feeding into compound
selection for in vivo testing and also
maybe a reducing convert or kind of test
or as a pre test for compounds going
into toxicology studies i think right
now if a few others is currently stirred
and but i mean that's quite enough data
yet to be able to say that and these
assays and technologies could replace
and existing in vivo toxicology studies
i think certainly the field has moved on
to a point res really worth going
through the exercise to test compounds
and building up correlations to see how
well compounds perform in these assays
and as compared to in vivo studies and
in toxicology experiments to see if
there is a way that they could
ultimately can have become a mainstay in
this drug discovery flowchart i think in
order to really move the field on the
still a number of and areas for
development around NPS technology in
general and it's very even really tell
you why they acknowledge right now the
microfluidic and learning the chip type
technology is fairly low through
and if we're thinking about doing those
responses for example that response
analysis of lead compound talking about
intensity of color say number of chips
which is it has a substantial cost
associated with that are currently
stands
- perhaps coupled with that chip
manufacturer and evolution of kind of
the synthesis of these chips and
increasing scale may ultimately drive
down cost in the future in addition to
which innovation around and alternative
ways to perfuse the chip so that may be
miniaturizing pumped to kind of increase
throughput could also be and really an
advantageous to really move this field
so there along as well and i think it's
a particularly a neat challenge for a
long delivery it's actually mimicking
inhaled air delivery that he just all a
challenge actually being able to mimic
the direct addition of a dry powder for
instance that a patient might take
inferred to reduce Airways tone
currently in the clinic so I think
trying to build in capabilities to mimic
inhalation delivery would also be a key
necessity as technology moves forward
and so I'd like to end down there thank
you for your attention in there take any
questions
thank you dr. Rowland's for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible now
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019 as
a final reminder our speaker will follow
up with any questions you submitted via
email that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon good back